welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and just when
you thought the news front for the
spider-man Sony situation was all quiet
we've just had a report come in that
Disney are in fact negotiating with Sony
over whether to purchase the entire
rights of the character rather than
constantly have this back and forth over
the deal we have a new story coming out
from we got this covered so take that
with a pinch of salt that the studio are
currently in talks with Sony over how
much it would cost to just outright
purchase the character from the studio
the story says that the source of this
is the same people that informed the
news website that she-hulk and MS marvel
were getting spin-off shows and they've
stated that Sony are looking for a
completely mind-blowing 10 billion
dollars for the rights of the character
and his universe Disney reportedly have
no intention of paying that and instead
of trying to borrow over the price to
see if they can reach a new deal now
we're in with this story before it picks
up a lot more steam but personally I
feel like this may be another false
story reported by the website though
Disney are no strangers to making big
purchases like this as we've seen with
how they bought Star Wars and Fox it
just seems too much of a big ask for one
character 10 billion dollars is a
ridiculous price and now I have faith
that spider-man is popular enough to
make that money back it is a big risk
now you have to look at this from Sony
side too they have just made their
highest-grossing movie in the studio's
history with spider-man far from home
which surpassed a billion dollars at the
box office
so naturally they'll probably be feeling
pretty confident and to me it seems
unlikely that they would want to part
with that Golden Boy I keep getting
asked on what I think of the entire Sony
and Disney situation and personally I do
believe that talks are ongoing however I
can't see a deal being reached at this
point till after the next spider-man
film in which Sony will have tested the
waters with the character to see if he
has enough legs excuse the spider pun to
stand unconnected from the MCU now
outright buying the character it does
seem like the best way to kind of negate
the deals and talks but the sheer price
that you would have to pay is
extortionate and Disney have enough hot
properties on their hands but they
aren't really hurting without spider-man
the studio has had an
we'll run this year with Lion King Toy
Story and all of the Marvel movies
passing 1 billion dollars and I'm
guessing that stores will do the same so
I don't really think that they're
desperate to get him back the MCU will
no doubt go on to be successful either
way and Sony probably want to see how
the character does fully at their studio
so I'm not sure exactly how ballad this
report is now we still haven't had a
full statement from Disney in regards to
the MCU and how they will continue
without the boy that they built up in
the last movie to be the next Iron Man
so there's still a potential that things
are being worked out behind the scenes
ten billion dollars though is a big ask
and I just can't see Sony wanting to
part with him at that price either as
he's pretty much the main thing that's
making money at the studio these days
this also been reports that Apple are
intending to buy Sony but I haven't
given any of these any airtime because
personally I just don't think it's true
there's a lot of monopoly laws and Sony
it's off as a corporation is absolutely
gigantic with divisions in film music
technology and so on so that seems kind
of like a rumor that's gotten out of
hand
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this report and if you think
it's true or not and if you do do you
think it's a good deal comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of every time
that Mysterio popped up in the
background of a scene in spider-man Thor
from home would you be linked after this
I go over the entire movie pointing out
the things you missed so it's definitely
worth checking out if you want to know
more also just want to let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
story in the comment section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from them to a baguette
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]